*best intro eva*
Why pewds, WHY!?!? D;
plz sub to stop ear rape
Whet is the funniest thing on the planet? *gasp* what? o:
kawaii face
That's right, FACESWAPS! OH MY GOED !!!!!! O:
AINSLEY (the greatest)
(pokemon) GO!
*Gasps* WHAT IS THIS DARK SORCERY
Hilarious! im crying
What if I told you,
there was a bot
that would do this for you? (are you serious?)
What if I told you about the greatest bot of all time? (you mean Snapchat -o-)
A bot  that lets you face swap (Too bad snapchat is already a thing)
[so its basicly google sounds boring :/]
*badass viking music plays* Marzias true form
VIKINGMUSIC
its called project murphy(eddie murphy fo life)
and you can ask it anything (Basically just like google) :/
*ultimate heartbeat sound effect*
we finally done it
[done what papa pewds?]
the science has mastered it
we could use this for greater good of mankind [So just like google sounds boring]
*epic violin music plays*
we could  ask it anything [We already have google for that though for the 5th time]
now lets ask what if keemstar.....
[What will the urban legend say about keemstar o:]
*more epic violin music plays*
Had hair *LOL that's obvious, NEVER*
phahahahahahahaahahaha he would look even dumber
*MOST KAWAII LAUGH EVER* (told you ha!0
Excuse me! I think it is a valid question *you're right pewds*
Dont you think so Ainsley? [No]
*rape stare*
*Japanese Female Google Translate Voice* "Yes"
Thank you very much for backing me up on that one [i should get paid for this]
What if leafy had a chin? [the world would explode]
*types*
japanese female robot* DonT dO iT
YoU cOUld diE
2 years studying Japanese, and now I'm writing subs on Ainsley's face. I have become immortal
I KNOW IT'S DANGEROUS AINSLEY , BUT I HAVE TO KNOW!!! [SO EXCITED TO KNOW]
WHY DID HITLER SHOW UP?! [because leafy is hitler and keemstar is trump]
i'm not joking WTF is that! [that's leafy]
I knew- I knew-I KNEW IT.....I KNEW IT!!!!!
I keep saying it but no-one listens!
c'mon I need to know for science!
TUHAH there we go!
I KNEW IT! x2
what if hitler *aka Leafy* was good?
[Lots of people wouldnt be dead if he was good]
everything would of been different
what if jackspeticeye was funny [He'd have a lot more subs]
HAHAHAHAH
you never know watcha gonna get x2
ok here we go  what if sorsha (Wasn't bat shit crazy vegan)
(Oh god not sorsha bitch!)
was a [sane] vegan hm?  *Impossible*
How about that remember the vegan girl? (How could we forget all she gets is dislikes now)
Sorsha bitch: So slutty
what if she was actually a vegan? (But she is
*Sorsha insane gibberish*
Da fuck is dis? were is she?
O00000000HHHHHHH!!!!! hahaha
WHY?
let me try that again
give me another option common
Dafauq are you doin? OOOOOHHHHH!
Now thats a real good faceswap *Nailed it*
Really really (Dank af no doubt)
that is fucking terrifying wtf happen there? {Exactly]
Ainsley! do something!
*microphone bang*
now this question pains me
what if harambe was alive (#DixoutforHarambe)
*Harambe music*
What?
That's Leslie Jones *NU NOT RACIST AT ALL* TOTALLY HARAMBE AS I REMEMBER HIM
No.
No!
Leslie Jones!
is not harambe (God dammit I thought she was!
Ainsley!
Lesley Jones Is NOT HARAMBE! SAY IT!!
WHY IS? LESLEY JONES
GOD NO GOD NO NOT LESLEY JONES
lets try again
what if Harambe was jesus (um pewds I wouldnt bring up that topic )
IS THIS SOME KIND OF JOKE! [Oh donkeh ballz.. HE'S BACK]
now thats pretty sexy
you know what fuck marzia I would fuck the shit out of that bitch (dont tell marzia
Oh wait its jacksepticeye  (PFFFFT HAHAHAHA)
god damn it...
Lesley Jones  for fucks sake ok can u just not?
that is Lesley Jones  on a white mans (leafys) face!
THAT IS RACIST I AM TRIGGERED FUCK  YOU! (Don't tell Marzia c;)
god damn it god fucking damn it x2
this is proof there is no god (Pewds dont go to the subject again not a good idea)
I know marina joyce *Whom I kidnapped*
what is kind at? what if marina joyce  was kidnapped (She was -.- BY YOU)
pupils  really does the trick doesnt it?
we got side tracked we need this for human..kind
what if trump was president (We would all go to world war 3)
that is so wrong
on so many levels
*music* ok heres the question everyones asking  what if pewdiepie was good?
(like that would  ever happen)
*Pirate music?*
*pewds falls*
Alright I hope you enjoyed this video and um Ainsley is  quitting (Yay!) we had a good run  didnt we?
ainsley *I will get my REVENGE PEWDS*
Now I left a twitter poll of who should replace ainsley so uh...
Leave a comment  down below Ainsley  we wish you the best of luck in the future on your future endeavors
wherever you will go we support you, and of course your welcome back anytime you want ainsley
Um... I hope you have a great  time *Lies*
and that maybe one you will uh- you will find  what you want to do in life and- *SOON I PROMISES*
feel free to uh...
uh say hi you know *OH I WILL*
anytime grab grab a beer (Aw pewds you seem so sad)
something like that
we wish you best of luck  everyone wish ainsley the best of luck in the future (Good luck Ainsleyl)
and uh *Extreme closeup* yeah love you guys so much
*Bye Ainsley*
and I'll see you bros in the next video (Oh god pewds needws help #Savepewds)
*Kisses majestic fist* stay awesome bros
Well wasnt that fun
Subtitles madE BY ALIENS IN UR BASEMENT
subscribe to pewds to get him at 50 million!
oh and yeah dont forget to vote on who will replace Ainsley
check out that video over there
Laterz~ GOOOBYE! ;D